welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity the Trump agenda despite what
the fake news is saying relations
between the Trump administration and
Russia are getting even colder the Trump
administration condemned Russia again
today after Moscow announced that it
will expel sixty US diplomats and close
a US consulate in st. Petersburg in
retaliation for president Trump's
decision to expel 60 of their diplomats
and close a Russian consulate in Seattle
president Trump's tough action was in
response to Russia's suspected poisoning
of an ex-spy and his daughter in Great
Britain earlier this month
but that's not the only foreign policy
issue the president is dealing with
today he also spoke about possibly
holding up a major trade agreement with
South Korea until the nuclear situation
in North Korea gets resolved take a look
I may hold it up till after a deal is
made with North Korea does everybody
understand that do you know why right do
you know why because it's a very strong
card and I want to make sure everyone is
treated fairly and we're moving along
very nicely with North Korea we'll see
what happens
certainly the new rhetoric has calmed
down just a little bit what do you say
would you say and we'll see how it all
turns out maybe it'll be good and maybe
it won't and if it's no good we're
walking and if it's good we will embrace
it
joining us now he's a member of the
House Foreign Affairs Committee Florida
congressman Ron De Santis
also joining us former Florida
congressman Fox News contributor Allen
West well I guess guys you both agree
that the rhetoric is it is clamping down
a bit and that's all good we don't we're
not hearing about Rocketman and all the
other stuff from Rocketman so I'll start
with you congressman DeSantis you know
you sit on the House Intelligence
Committee you know what we've got today
with the expulsion of you know the
Russian diplomats and then their
retaliation or tit-for-tat although the
the the issue is that you know we had a
reason for the TAT it was the the
British spy
was poisoned on the UK grounds his
daughter I understand is still alive but
is getting better they had no reason
other than retaliation what does that
tell you about Russia and the United
States well tells me that under the
Trump administration they've had a
policy of being very firm against Russia
which is in contrast to the Obama
administration you remember when Obama
was then they try to reset they did
nothing when Russia invaded Crimea made
incursions into Ukraine
went into Syria what is this president
done Donald Trump since he's been in
office he has provided lethal aid to
Ukraine so they could defend themselves
Obama wouldn't do that he's provided
Patriot missiles to Poland so they can
defend themselves
he struck Assad in Syria which Obama
wouldn't do and force the red line and
then he's really committed to expanding
America's oil and gas capability Russia
at the end of the day you know they have
nuclear weapons but they're a big gas
station and the extent that we're
challenging them with our exports to
Europe that's going to weaken Putin so
this is a president that's been strong
against Russia and and Colonel Allen
West I mean you know when we talk about
a cold war and there is talk now that we
may be entering into a new phase which
is almost ironic given the fact that the
Democrats keep saying that the Trump
team colluded with Russia and after 15
months they've come up with zilch but do
you think we're entering a new Cold War
era without a doubt to us we are getting
there you know when Vladimir Putin was
asked about the greatest disappointment
he had in the twentieth century he said
it was the collapse of the old Soviet
Union so what you see is someone that is
trying to re-establish that Russian
hegemonic dominance
you know the threats that he's made
against the Baltic States Latvia
Lithuania and Estonia Congressman De
Santis already talked about some of the
threats that he is made with the Crimea
and the Ukraine and so he has done that
because he has not seen a very strong
policy you're starting to see that type
of strong policy and with the
announcement that John Bolton is going
to be the National Security Advisor I
don't think you will get the same type
of weak and feckless advice that a Susan
Rice was given to President Barack Obama
yeah and
you're nodding your head well yeah I
mean you know John Bolton you know it
was a very strong voice very clear
thinker and I think that importantly he
knows how the bureaucracy works and so
he's going to be instrumental in getting
the bureaucrats to actually enforce
president Trump's policies which they
haven't been you know is willing to do
as they were under Obama so I think was
a really good choice and I do think that
you will see positive results in terms
of the execution of the Trump foreign
policy and you know what about with the
president talking about you know the
North Korea situation and the fact that
you know he's got a strong card now Alan
as it relates to North and South Korea
well it's been very interesting we know
that kim jeong-hoon the first time he
has ever left North Korea that was this
week to go and travel and sit down with
Zhi Jing ping in China I think the China
and North Korea are very nervous they
understand that the president number one
this is not about strategic patience
number two he note they know that the
president will put pressure on China and
definitely pressure on North Korea and
he is not backing down and so they find
themselves in a very precarious
situation and I think Zhi Jing ping
wants to make sure the kim jeong-hoon is
very clear and understanding that china
cannot have a Korean Peninsula that is
friendly to the United States of America
Japan or our allies as opposed to a
China China cannot afford for an
implosion that happened in North Korea
with the mass influx of refugees and
also the loss of the hydroelectric power
plants that provide a lot of electricity
for those northern provinces in China
interesting and and and back to you Iran
a congressman two scientists you know we
saw kim jeong-hoon for the first year of
the president's administration first 13
14 months you know was setting off those
ICBMs and and you know with all the
name-calling and saying we were going to
get a birthday present you know on the
4th of July and all that other stuff all
of a sudden he's he's starting to dress
in kind of western gear kind of and
these go he's making trips outside of
his country what do you think has caused
this man to do this abrupt turn around
well I think it's the
pressure that the president and his
administration have put on North Korea
and on China to a certain extent and
we've made more progress on that and
look we're a long way to go it's a very
difficult problem Kim jong-un is a thug
but I will say that that the Trump
administration has made more progress in
15 months than his predecessors did in
the last quarter century so a lot of
work left to do but I think the
president deserves credit that were on
the brink of potentially finally getting
some good resolution here and very
quickly finally Alan the whole idea of
you know without the the Russian
diplomats here you know we are also in
addition to the Cold War as you
mentioned entering a new period where
there can be continuing cyber attacks
you don't really need to be on the
homeland you know they call them hybrid
warfare cyber attacks
that's certainly potential yes yes
you're absolutely right that's that new
dimension of warfare we see that from
China we see it from Russia we see it
from North Korea and I think that that's
one of the critical things when the
president sits down with kim jeong-hoon
to get them to curtail their cyber
warfare programs and their aggressive
actions as well as he needs to express
that to China but without a doubt we
need to understand we've got a block
Russia in every way shape form and
fashion all right thank you very much
congressman